welcome to this video I'm playing motor
home motor home from the US let's play
the comic-con for a change ok the
advance the modern main line of the
caro-kann ok trying to play very solid
set up m simply because i feel i should
do something wrong yeah that that's not
so theoretically demanding I don't know
the details of those this opening really
can I do something on the Kings side
like tweenage for my favorite move can I
get this in or is this naive may be this
naive right now now we're going to get
get a check made in against against this
king i guess but ok the night on a five
is some preparing the c5 advance or is
this I think it's ok i should i should
get this going if he takes now Bishop
takes have well-developed somehow his
early night edge form did it did cost it
took some time
hmm so that has that isn't bad for me
right this pollution
a ya novel if he goes Knight d2 for
example a 92 12 3 as a plan I just
grabbed your form they don't see a
compensation what exactly is White's
move in this position yeah this is
really really ugly and maybe he needed
to do it and look so does not look great
Queen B 6 or not hmm camp looks looks
got him going to be 6 he still has
development problems he goes Bishop b2
let's say I take group c 8 something
like that is looking on move the night
oh wow this is this is risky definitely
hmm
okay i don't think i can sacrifice
something if i go to e7 he might take
him I didn't take but with that dad's
excellent right i get i get knight c6 m
hmm yeah I can play Bishop e3 though all
of a sudden if I reroute the Queen
I wonder why isn't this why isn't this
really good for me and did I did them I
do something to make some mistake here
we had okay I need you shouldn't think
about it for ages
maybe I I needed to do something against
this chief for move yeah he possibly has
good night a for even here i am and
night a four-night c700 night a 495
sorry not see seven of course
yeah this is obviously risky but I don't
know I don't know what to do i'm glad
that he's got b3 end as this seems
helpful so the dark squares I at least
weekend a bit hmm some way maybe f6 yeah
like f6 takes bishop cakes and I really
have pressure against the form may be F
success is a resource that have
underestimated still I guess yeah and
maybe even g5 just breaking the whole
structure
hmm that's not so bad maybe okay
okay interesting I wasn't really sure
what's best now both both all three
moves logo ballad texting special checks
ok I go here and take on the form a
check here a three maybe why a three
years is really really working
III 90-95 a be 93 Korea's crazy stuff
now can we come on I don't have any time
I don't know maybe you can just move the
Queen away tweenty one moves like that
yeah probably what am i doing now time
maybe maybe still maybe grab there still
I made a mistake yeah I thought I can
take be three but if I've hangs with the
check the check is really a problem
Queen age 3 as a little thing yeah and I
have going for me but I'm not sure how
bad it is yeah he's got some some stuff
on my king as well of course Queen here
15 my family here Wow Jack I just hope
that I'm not checkmated I cannot
calculate this I forgot about this
simple idea Oh jack
Wow check Joe Jeff check
check white for Faison I have no idea
what's going on what this is their made
on what who Bishop c4 check cakes check
checkmate mate there is a mate yeah
complete insanity of course yeah well
that was interesting that was
interesting I think and right here how
like something is wrong for wide with BB
3 is really ugly stuff if you have to
place something like that but maybe it's
not such a big problem I actually
believe I went here I should probably
take first and and then then look did
you to have him put it on Batu really so
that he cannot go Bishop e3 I really
prefer that quite quite a bit I wasn't
really thinking about g4 well that's a
good move now he gets in the Bishop to
e3 and the rising position is really
totally totally unclear mmm yeah maybe
it maybe this wasn't a good idea man I
don't know yeah this is active but also
true key yeah Bishop takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes f6 and Bishop takes d4 is
just not working I thought that this
could be interesting if he goes
something like that very very
complicated and of course I can take
with the porn which has one advantage
like here i'm covering f4 and s11 t5
yeah that's it's quite good actually
again this this is not working I really
thought that
this might be a move but he can just do
that yeah and he I'm just just trying to
confuse him or whatever Luke F sound is
already made in a couple of moves yeah
yeah this is just total total crapshoot
he didn't see Queen a dream yeah time
time scramble in blitz okay funny and at
the at least thanks for watching